there's a certain type of woman and I've
just noticed this archetype they'll
they'll claim that all women have to do
is raise their standards for men and
then they're going to magically get the
man that they want they've read the book
why men love and they often
encourage things like a three-month rule
for dating now the problem with these
women is they often sell you a dream and
sell you a course now me I'm not selling
anything so you guys can take my advice
or leave it if you are raising your
price and you're not raising your value
and you find someone that buys it who is
your buyer a fool
Now ladies do you really want to do you
really want to marry someone that's
clearly a fool and you always see these
girls with their boyfriends like they
walk all over their boyfriends they
usually lead the relationship and
they're miserable they're miserable but
you know that's just my two cents just
my analysis take it or leave it